you got helical symmetry right line
symmetry points retreat one last one and
even though it sounds simple it's
actually the most interesting of all the
folk scales soon what do you think this
means scale it's about size isn't it
scale is a scale as a size word now it's
2d but we're going to do together and
this is what most of your most of your
pens and pencils or rules were before
we're going to make some things which
with really interesting scale symmetry
let's give a simple boring example first
okay
scale symmetry you just want to take a
shape take a shape right let's say and
then you want to think about well what
would happen if I scaled it if I resize
them if I scale it down like this let
make it say 10% or 15% smaller bigger
these two shapes or this shape has scale
symmetry but I can resize it there is I
can keep going
I can go in lots of times yeah that's
right it's it's square ception
okay now like I said this is a boring
simple example just so you can wrap your
head around scale symmetry but where it
gets really really fun is where you
start to combine some of these
symmetries okay it's where you start to
combine them so I'm going to give you
two really cool really interesting
examples first we'll just go off the
square okay I'm gonna start this off but
I want you to do this properly I'm gonna
do kind of like the shortcut version
okay this is scale symmetry I'm going to
add on to it point symmetry right so not
only am I going to shrink things now but
I'm also going to add a an angle a
rotation okay now here's a really easy
way to do it okay
join yourself up a square okay we'll
start off and then you can finish it in
your own time make it as big as you can
okay on your on the page that you have
because it's going to go go in and
become quite small now to make this nice
and easy what we're gonna do is I'm
going to put the midpoint on each side
like that and then now watch carefully
this part put your pins down and look up
so you don't miss this I'm going to see
i bisected this lock this time I can't
even point I'm going to bisect a few
more times
this one this one yeah this one here
this one here and this one here okay so
now I advise ected i bisected again
right now with these points on each of
the corners I'm going to join them up
like this look mine's not very good as
you can see okay but there you go can
you see how to scaled it this new shape
you're gonna throw is better than mine
obviously is this shape is also square
right but it's three quarters like well
I've sort of done a 75 percent scaling
thing I'd really do okay so then you can
do it again you can bisect bisect bisect
bisect West no place that you get the
idea right and then I'm gonna join up
all of these like sir okay so you can
see what's happening it's gonna spiral
in I'm gonna try and hurry up a little
bit here it will look something like
this and then it'll look something like
this okay so you can see it's when you
combine symmetries that stuff started to
get really interesting
why would that be why would this look
like wow because you're kind of right
aren't you like if you saw stare into
there it looks kind of like alright now
I propose a question to you as your keep
still constructing that we put together
like this is this is scale symmetry and
that what we added to it was point
symmetry right now I wonder like what
we've got now by putting these two
switches together is kind of like a new
symmetry like it isn't its own thing
because we've you know we've boiler we
can boil it down to these but if you had
to name this symmetry what might you
call this hmm
now yeah maybe you call it flower rotors
symmetry so like that I'm very tempted
to climb to call it like it's a 2d
version of that helical symmetry I
showed you before right like it's this
guy right he gets a bit tangled I'm
sorry
okay it's this guy right if you stretch
him out on a third dimension
okay like this that's what gives you
this spiral business but if you put him
back together and then look look
straight on that's what you kind of got
like you can see it spiraling yeah right
and if I could golden spiral
demonstrates exactly the same kind of
symmetry right it's neither points in
between your scales tree on its own it's
kind of kind of some weird mix of both